by the time I get back the wings are
locked down tomorrow quick catch up with
the boys tomorrow
thank you
hello guys listen they flew off the
shelf over the last task we're going as
well penguinese everyone who came in
there i said how does that make you feel
yeah that this yeah was made by prison
said you know what we are so dad to do
something yeah yeah you're so glad that
they're yeah alright do nothing you made
over 300 pounds profit message from Josh
you got a diamond without projects like
this
we're just looking people up they are
just people at the end of the day albeit
that they've committed crime and they're
now in prison but they are still human
beings with feelings as well we've got
I make a difference after today I can
see my baby's got a real future here but
for one of my team it's the end
Jerome Samuels behavior has finally seen
him kicked out of my brigade so
frustrating you know I had him on that
lying that straight narrow yes it wasn't
for months years but he found something
and got that little glimmer of bang I
want that I know he's not an angel we
know that but is it right thrown back in
the cell and forget about no it's not
fair right how are you what's going on
you tell me what's the course around two
months time what's gonna happen I don't
know oh god you don't that's why I
jumped on his course to change my life
obviously I want to close now so what's
the fight I know but I give up easily
ain't got time for wasting wasting I
don't want to sit on a street brawl I do
to Brogdon
how is this gonna stop if you revert
back into that mode they give up on you
and you don't hold on to that chance
how's this never gonna change oh no
she's tell unit I'm trying I've gone
down the legit road I've been there
don't work if I woke up tomorrow if I
was your business and I give you a
disclosure statement with my three
Street you are not gonna hire me don't
stand here and lie to my face because
that was the insult you would never hire
me with my record never but it takes
time to change that
you can't changes only so what you can
do now don't give up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]